hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich muss zum friseur
er wisse was sich um eine kerb ein paar
sekunden später sie heute versammelt
aufgrund einer neuen episode whatsapp
fails meine lieben freunde was wir
lassen das mit der keb das hier ist der
erste wort fällt uns vorschreibt eine
person in den lieben robin die nachricht
hallo robin schaffst du es um 13 uhr
dann zum termin und robin antwortet 13
uhr werde ich nicht ganz schaffen aber
ich komme
[Musik]
robin ist nicht schlimm wenn er 13
geschafft weil wir danach kommt dann
wissen ist ihr film radio antenne hast
du gerade viel zu tun wenn am aber geht
packen
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ach ja die autokorrektur man kennt und
liebt wie beim nächsten fehler hat ein
junge seine freundin nach der meinung
seiner jacke und einem hemd gefragt und
die freundin antwortet cool und
daraufhin schreibt der freund soll ich
kaufen
36 euro und hemmt 18 euro jacke hhk für
36 euro finde ich ein wenig viel
falls ihr euch übrigens fragt warum ich
das wort die ganze zensieren muss
youtube
sonst wird das video bei vielen nicht in
das land
es ist ein schwieriges thema paul felix
ich habe gerade wird und musste an dich
denken und da dachte ich ich schicke dir
nochmal liebe grüße ob mama um gottes
willen ich meinte mit meditiert was
stimmt nicht mit diesem telefon sowie
kleiner 8 die autokorrektur mal wieder
eine autokorrektur und mütter zusammen
ist der ganz schlimme kombination finde
ich apropos glaube ich auch mal diese
zitate vorbereitet die autokorrektur
treibt mich irgendwann noch in den
warenkorb vor allem zitat das ist doch
kein zitat so als wenn das jetzt goethe
damals gesagt hätte machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit diesem ortsteil und
zwar schreibt eine person ich bin jetzt
bei media markt habe auch durchfall
nein keinen durchfall duschgel haha ich
bei kaufland
ich fand
stumpf verantwortlich bei kaufland fast
schon besser ich bin auch so eine
lebende autokorrektur feld
die autokultur wahrscheinlich rot ist
super vielen dank dlz gdl zg vor allem
auf jeden fall antwortet die person dann
super das freut mich die hose
hoffentlich auch uns ja hose oder dhl wo
bestellt die lieber oh mein gott dieser
wird zwar so schlecht liebe frau unnötig
antonio geht es klasse wie er sagt
findet er ist richtig toll hier ich gebe
ihm nachher das handy um anzurufen liebe
grüße hahaha autokorrektur danke das
freut mich sehr
entschuldigung das ist ja peinlich zum
bieten natürlich ja unnötig
als komischer weibchen heute im video
auch ein ganz komischer weit ist diese
nachricht habe in anderthalb stunden
feuerbestattung hh feierabend hahaha ich
hab richtig hunger und ich glaube ich
bin mit dem falschen bein aufgestanden
ich las zum töten einfach die sporthose
an töten sagt nicht du hast wieder
vergessen dass wir das heute machen
wollten ich habe bestimmt nicht zugesagt
jemanden umzubringen tönen tönen haare
tönen liebe nsa und sonstige behörden
ich bin kein mörder anderen
friedliebender mensch kennt ihr das
eigentlich oder habt ihr das auch
manchmal dass sie eine nachricht
schreiben wollt in der gruppe oder einem
freund oder eine freundin und ich denke
wenn wir irgend jemand von der nsa
gerade mitliest die würden mich direkt
einschwören
hey wie heißt noch mal diese band aus
island die zum new pop festival kommt
kamel
ich finde keine songs von denen es cacau
mein ich ach mist kaleo soll das heißen
bruder
ich hab da eine empfehlung für dich
sprachenlernen fleisch salate gelbwurst
zum mittagessen hähnchenbrust und kaufe
doch pommer hommels hh
dann essen wir salat dazu und die
hähnchenbrust alles klar dass ich viel
erstaunlicher finde ist dass die person
das um 7 uhr 53 schreibt weil ich gerade
zumindest in der quarantäne
für mich wäre das mitten in der nacht
apropos quarantäne übrigens meine lieben
freunde warum sage ich überhaupt immer
meine lieben freunde ich habe keine
freunde geht ihr eigentlich schon wieder
zur schule oder habt ihr immer noch
zuhause unterricht mit hausaufgaben und
so weiter und so fort stimmt hier oben
gern mal ab bei der umfrage würde mich
echt überhaupt nicht interessieren
karaoke hho ich liebe carola omg
kataloge und wer's carola katapulte
karaoke roth
geil ich habe noch eine alte packung
japan im schrank gefunden die habe ich
erst mal weg gemacht das war mein
zuckerschlecken für heute abend ab 1
wieso macht die autokorrektur ausbau am
napalm alter und es sollte zuckerschock
heißen aber zuckerschlecken war es auch
maximal los die person ich hatte heute
eine augenoperation mit laser ich bin
seit heute morgen blind und das noch
drei tage lang wie das denn verarschen
wieso meine augen waren wohl zu schwach
ich werde erst in drei tagen wieder
sehen können wo man das hat mir jetzt
echt schlechte laune gemacht egal bruder
wir sehen uns morgen in der schule ich
schaue mir jetzt noch eben einen film an
bin offline halt die ohren steif und die
augen immer auf ok ich bete zu gott dass
es wieder gut wird danke ich bete auch
zu gott dass er dir ein vollständiges
gehirn gibt ich weiß nicht was ich hier
merke ich finde dass die person die
andere person verarscht mit einer
augenoperation dass sie eine person das
dann aber nicht checks oder dass beide
personen einfach komplett kein deutsch
können oder auch satzzeichen vergessen
das allerdings konnten wir auch wieder
auf instagram einige whatsapp welt zu
senden falls mir auf jeden fall möglich
folglich heißt der laser lukas kann ich
niemandem empfehlen weil ich lauter halb
nackt bilder in letzter zeit irgendwie
hoch auf jeden fall habt ihr mir auch
dort wieder einige motzfeld zukommen
lassen und die staaten direkt mit diesem
hier
hey hey my way
ja ich frage mich echt gar nichts mehr
bei euch hier frage ich mich auch nichts
mehr ein was für gruppen seid ihr dass
da alle 20 sekunden vetter video call
verpasst wird und das hier ist ein chat
verlauf zwischen einem mädchen und ihrer
mutter und zwar schreibt die mutter
hallo winkt alles um sie antwortet ja
alles oder auch hier
hallo wie geht es dir schreibt die
mutter und lebst du noch und sie fragt
weight watchers 2 ok es das pt pd die
nbn co 2 ja ich verstehe nur bahnhof
hey hast du die hausaufgaben in englisch
ja kannst du sie mir schicken ja hast du
schon die aufgaben in mathe matte was
war denn da auf und das ist ein
versinnbildlichung meiner kompletten
schulzeit sondern fragt sie in einen
frei nach den hausaufgaben in englischen
antwortet die person ja auch noch ja
hast auch noch pädagogik mathe deutsch
das hier tobt aber alles meine lieben
freunde einer 59 minuten lange
sprachnachricht und die person antwortet
nur noch nie einfach nie
das brauchen 950 minuten werden die
anziehen gemacht
man darf ja keine bösen und wörter hier
mehr sagen seid 2020 auf youtube.com mir
allerdings auch schon zum letzten luke
roberts entfällt fürs heutige video aber
die arbeit macht mir spaß ja klar und
wenig ist es ja auch nicht um die ganzen
annehmlichkeiten sind auch toll mehr
urlaub und gleitzeit und soja und die
kollegen sind nett spielt auch eine
tolle rolle
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha das spielt eine
große rolle
hahahahaha ja
ich genauso
sich absolut genauso hobby nun
allerdings auch schon zu den letzten
fünf whatsapp fällt fürs heutige video
allerdings sind es wieder keine
richtigen whatsapp feld sondern kreative
in moshi nachrichten
ich weiß ihr freut euch da schon drauf
keiner freut sich darauf dass die jetzt
auf jeden fall der erste und zwar hat
dort jemand einen himmel gemacht eine
landschaft hinten mit vier bäumen hat
eine straße gemacht er hat verschiedene
polizeiautos und ein auto was unten
fährt mit dem untertitel daisy me roll
day hayton
das hier ist das nächste meine lieben
freunde es ist wieder eine
verfolgungsjagd mit der polizei
allerdings fährt diesmal nicht ein auto
vor der polizei weg sondern ein junge
rennt weg und bei diesem bild das ist so
eine richtige nachricht wo dann so die
laras schreiben würden wir haben auf
jeden fall eine wiese auf der ein
pärchen steht die beide genau so groß
sind wie die wie die gräser die haben
auf jeden fall einen regenschirm denn es
regnet und gewittert und ganz oben sind
sogar aliens okay das hier ist das
nächste uns schon vorletzte creative im
motiv er habe ich gerade creative gesagt
englisch muss auch gelernt sein
auf jeden fall ist es eine anlehnung an
das spiel space invaders ist es eine
anlegerin und da schauen wir uns hier
jetzt auch endlich den letzten kreativen
dem motto text an und war dort eine
person einen mann gemacht mit ihm moniz
der gerade von der arbeit kommen denn er
sagt hanni einem hoben daraufhin
antwortet die frau burke am handy und
das baby macht einfach nur da und an der
stelle meine lieben freunde beende ich
jetzt doch endlich das heutige video ich
glaube es ist für uns alle eine erlösung
dass ich euch jetzt endlich in ruhe
lassen von daher würde ich sagen komm
mir direkt ins auto jetzt ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn du drauf klickt main
kanal abonnieren wenigstens taktik noch
die glocke und bekommt eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich was neues hoch
laden und hier ist ein video was zudem
auf ein zweiter kanal online gegangen
ist das endet wenn monte dicker sagt
eine neue challenge cups
[Musik]